good morning it's tuesday in your video
last week about what 10 year old you
thought would happen before the year
2020 you detailed many of those
childhood predictions but you almost
completely skipped over your prediction
for the year 2012.
zoom in enhance superior fish beings
hank your prediction that the year 2012
would feature the emergence of superior
fish beings is so
weird and wonderful that in the entire
history of the world wide web at least
according to google
no one has ever used the phrase superior
fish beings
i mean did you believe that fish-like
aliens were going to visit us from a
distant planet or did you believe that
via some extremely speedy form of
evolution
a hyper-intelligent fish species would
evolve and form their own civilizations
like in our beloved childhood cartoon
the snorks
or did you believe that all along in the
rivers and lakes and oceans of earth
there had been superior fish beings that
were waiting until the year 2012
to reveal themselves because by that
definition hank and i'm gonna say this
as vaguely as possible to minimize
spoilers
adult you has arguably written the two
greatest
superior fish-being novels of the 21st
century albeit with minimal actual fish
beings
and i wonder if this idea has just been
floating around in your head this whole
time like over the years you and i would
often speculate about what would happen
if the gods of mount olympus or the
creators of the simulation or superior
fish beings or whatever
suddenly announced themselves and were
like okay yeah this has gone on long
enough i'll tell you what i would be
nervous if superior fish beings
announced their arrival tomorrow but i
would also be
like a little relieved like thank god
someone around here actually knows more
than we do also just the fact that the
superior fish beings have chosen to stay
quiet
up to now bodes well i mean it means
they have the ability to stay calm and
shut up two talents humanity has shown a
limited capacity for what would the
superior fish being say i suppose they
might begin by telling us to more
carefully consider the long-term
consequences of our actions especially
as it relates to large-scale changes to
the rivers and lakes the superior fish
beings are used to
they might also be able to tell us what
the deal is with dark matter and how to
better account for the value of natural
resources in our economic systems and
also they might be able to explain to me
why sometimes at night when i am trying
to fall asleep i cannot stop thinking
about how the snorks
would sometimes blow bubbles out of
their little head snorkels when they
were nervous
but where where did the bubbles come
from they didn't where where
where's the air now of course i am also
aware that the superior fish beings
could use their amazing technology and
great wisdom to
crush or conquer us or worse still
humanity in all of its hubris could try
to take on the superior fish beings
leading to our inevitable humiliation
and defeat
but i like to imagine the superior fish
beings would just answer all of our
questions and
provide us with loving guidance without
ordering us to do
this or that in short i sometimes feel
like humanity is an early adolescent in
need of good parental figures
specifically parental figures in the
form of superior fish beings
but the thing is hank i think much of
what the superior fish beings would tell
us
we already know like we already know
that war is bad and that humans and
other superior beings accomplish more in
collaboration than they do in isolation
and that every person deserves
access to health care and educational
opportunities we already know that as a
species we are at once far
too powerful and not nearly powerful
enough
powerful enough to change the climate of
our planet but not
powerful enough to choose how we change
the climate of our planet
and in that sense it could be that the
superior fish beings have already
emerged we just need to learn
to listen to them oh my god did i just
turn a video about superior fish beings
into something completely earnest i
can't help myself hank
unironic earnest enthusiasm about
superior fish beings and other is part
of my 2021 vision board
anyway hank i for one welcome our new
superior fish being overlords
i will see you on friday